despite claiming that he never thinks
about Ron DeSantis failed former
president Donald Trump is clearly
obsessed with Ron DeSantis and that
obsession is starting to become very
very unhealthy it is abundantly clear
and it is supported by the fact that
Donald Trump sees Ron DeSantis as
potentially his most powerful Challenger
in the 2024 Republican primary now Ronda
sandis still hasn't announced that he is
running we talked earlier in the show
about why that might be and when his
announcement might be coming if indeed
he plans to make that announcement
Donald Trump is posting daily to his
platform truth social about Ron DeSantis
I hope that anybody who is planning on
following the 2024 election is prepared
for more than a year of what we saw over
the last four days take a look at some
of these childish and ridiculous posts
from the failed former president who's
nearly 80 years old this is not a kid
that we're talking about first posting
about the size of Ron desantis's
crowd quote very small crowds for Ron de
sanctimonious and Iowa he's against
capital F Farmers Social Security and
Medicare so why would people show up
other than capital F fake stories from
the capital F fake capital N news the
random capitalization and the lies both
Staples of Donald Trump's posts as we
talked about before
attacking DeSantis on Social Security
and Medicare is a little shaky given
Trump's own history with submitting
Federal budgets that would cut Social
Security okay then Trump goes on to
comparing his book to Ron desantis's
book posting quote summon the fake news
are falsely stating that Ronde
sanctimonius's book is doing as well as
letters to Trump my new book this is
fake news in that letters doesn't even
come out until April 25th Ron has groups
buying his book in order to inflate
sales and in fact on the first day his
book was already 30 percent discounted
letters to Trump has much different
pricing and is a coffee table book the
so-called Stars corresponded with me
you'll love it pre-order the book so
couple different things there of course
Donald Trump just obsessed with
comparing the size of all of his things
to that of Ron DeSantis and Trump is not
mentioning that Don Jr's book also
benefited from groups buying the book
this is actually a really common thing
it's particularly common on the right
although maybe it does happen on the
left as well but when large right-wing
figures whose followers barely read I
mean let's be let's be really really
honest with each other here do you think
the average Don Jr follower reads books
where would you put the over under on
the number of books the average Don Jr
follower reads and I hate folks that
this is it sounds so a Leo but David
reading oh but come on Trump himself
hasn't read a book in his adult life and
we're supposed to pretend Don's fault
Don Jr's followers read books Don Jr's
book benefited greatly
from people groups buying the book and
then giving it out when Don Jr speaks
and this sort of thing okay then Trump
continuing to be obsessed with um Ron
DeSantis posts the results to a
meaningless online poll about 2024 where
15 000 people click the button online
and said they preferred to Santa they
prefer Trump to DeSantis by two to one
now I I believe Trump is winning uh but
Trump just put posting garbage polls and
then Trump posting quote Ron de
sanctimonious totally caved in his
public relations inspired battle with
Disney the that's the only reason he
went after them in the first place to
show Mr tough guy Disney maintained
complete exemption from property and
sales tax tax-free bonds and their
incredible Fast Track permitting they
also gave big political contributions to
Des Sanctus the whole thing is a capital
H hoax they probably work together to
make them look like a fighter read Rick
Fogle song preeminent Authority on
Disney I could keep going back to last
week but I won't
this might be the most childish and
ridiculous primary that we ever see and
meanwhile on the Democratic side there
may be no primary if Joe Biden runs for
re-election which some people say isn't
good there are people on the left who
say forget about its impact on the
general the Democratic party should have
a real primary if there are people
challenging Joe Biden there should be a
real primary and there should be debates
and so on and so forth there uh I
understand that perspective and we're
going to talk about that more maybe a
little bit later this week or maybe once
we we hear from a couple other
candidates who plan to declare but Trump
obsessed unhealthily with Ron DeSantis
one of our sponsors is zipx nicotine
toothpicks don't you think it's time you
stopped putting smoke and vape oils in
your lungs zippix toothpicks are a
convenient way to curb the nicotine
Cravings zipx toothpicks are super
discreet you can use them anytime
anywhere smoking and vaping aren't
allowed including flights sporting
events in restaurants they're available
in six different flavors with options of
two and three milligrams of nicotine if
you're not a nicotine user zipix also
offers caffeine and b12 infused
toothpicks zipx has already helped tens
of thousands of customers ditch the
cigarettes ditch the Vapes they might be
able to help you too if you're a smoker
or a vapor give zipx toothpicks a try
your lungs will thank you go to
zipxtoothpix.com today save 10 percent
with the code pacman10 at checkout out
just remember you must be 21 or older to
order the link is down below